Oh sorry, didn’t see you there, I was just
doing my pre-DNews routine.
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews.
A recent poll by the National Sleep Foundation
found that most parents understand that sleep
is important for their kid’s growing brains.
Yet 90% of kids aren’t getting enough sleep.
In order to get kids to sleep better, the
researchers encourage parents to adopt bedtime
routines.
Reading before bed rather than letting them
play with a tablet device for example.
Alright, yeah so going to bed and getting
up at the same time every day is good for
us.
But this made me ask why?
Why are we so obsessed with habits?
I mean, how many listicles are on the internet
about “habits of highly successful people”?
it’s like we see magic in routines.
Writers often stick very strictly to their
routines, they feel it opens them to be a
conduit for creativity.
Routines aren’t just for writers, how many
of us make the same cup of coffee in the same
mug and sit in the same chair.
How many of you go through your morning routine
in a fog?
how many us drive to and from work without
too much thought?
Well thank your infralimbic cortex and the
basal ganglia for that.
These two parts of the brain work together
to form our most cherished routines.
The infralimbic cortex, which is located in
the prefrontal cortex, is the decider.
the basal ganglia and the brainstem work together
to execute your actions.
the basal ganglia are responsible for positive
reinforcement.
While learning a new habit, this part of the
brain is influxed with dopamine, which reinforces
the behavior.
These actions are then stored in the striatum
and its circuits.
Over time, as your perform these habits, your
brain goes on autopilot mode.
This nifty autopilot feature isn’t because
you need more caffeine but it keeps the brain
from feeling overwhelmed.
During the routine, the prefrontal cortex
isn’t as active, leaving you able to think
about other things.
Imagine if you have had to consciously decide
where to put your feet or which side of the
sink you should stand on.
These small decisions would take up so much
brain space.
Life would be very difficult.
Writer Alva Noe suggests that habits are what
make daily life possible.
That habits allow us the freedom to pursue
other thoughts or actions while getting stuff
done.
He even suggests we design robots or AI with
habits.
Habits, routines and rituals all play through
this positive feedback track.
Rituals are just routines granted meaningful
significance.
There’s comfort in routine.
Indeed they apply some modicum of control
over our lives.
When faced with anxiety we turn to the things
we can control.
Faced with a big game?
Wear your lucky jersey.
Faced with the illness of a loved one?
Go to the store, buy some soup and crackers,
turn on a favorite movie.
To ward off nightmares as a kid I would kiss
my dream catcher every night before I went
to bed.
A recent study shows that rituals boost confidence
and temper the effects of feelings of grief
or even less intense emotions like disappointment.
Whether a large religious ritual or a small
bedtime routine, humans are creatures of habit.
And it’s not all magic and superstition.
Some of it’s science.
And switching gears for a second, our sister
show TestTube is getting super close to 250,000
subscribers!
Go check out this video the amazing Chastity
hosted on whether or not vaccinations should
be mandatory.
Check it out, subscribe, and we’ll see you
next time on Dnews
Alright dudes, throwing it back you, what
are some your habits or routines?